if you don't mind oh I want to talk to
you about one of your earlier games one
of my favorite games just briefly before
we imma krondon oh my soul my god
Quantic Dream's first your adapter old
yes I know yeah I got the gray hair I
turned 30 this year and but I love that
game and obviously earlier this year we
lost David Bowie in January and that was
I believe the only game that he was was
in or the I giving Sarah yeah and it's
what was it like working with him do you
remember as their father memories editor
well it was my very first game really
and yeah remember the first time we met
actually I mean we were supposed to meet
in the publishers office in London hmm
and I thought he would never come I
thought all this was just you know we'd
never happened and actually it was like
10 minutes late all right and we're all
looking at our watches thinking oh is
never gonna make it and then 10 minutes
later he arrived in your pool guys were
being laid because of the traffic or if
and he came with a young kid it was
maybe 14 years old right I mean he said
okay this is my video game expert is my
son Duncan Jones yes who became of
course the directory that we know yeah
of moon and of course world of warcraft
and so it was really funny because i met
both at the same time we had a wonderful
collaboration together that lasted a
year right and he wrote about 12
original songs and then and i had the
pleasure to direct him in studio because
he would play two roles in the game so
well it's a fantastic experience of
course as you can imagine and it was a
fantastic person right that was actually
how I found out about David Bowie was I
i I'd never found his music and then I
remember walking into was it the bar
where yeah the band is playing for the
first time and it takes control away
from you and chilled me does the music
video and then I was like what is this
my aunt I found out and bought me a
David Bowie album then so I introduced
you did so thank you so much my god for
giving me the gift of David Bowie and to
all of a night pleasure